jose what was um the gun rights like in
cuba
in the 40s and the 50s you could have
your guns and
uh you could go you know
and uh target practice don't know
there was no problem and cuba was
very peaceful we we
for for guns to be
something so bad uh
some illness have to be
in the minds of so many people that they
use them wrong
probably but the problem are not the
guns are the people
and if you and if you have people that
hate
uh whether it's a gun or not you can go
and smash somebody's head or destroy
somebody's property
which is the same thing and you can do
it with a gun or with no gun
did bautista take the guns no
castro no no yes what year yeah in 1959
i tell you i tell you what there was a
speech a famous speech of ideal
the problem is this fidel takes over
but really there are other organizations
and movements
that also had guerrilla forces fighting
batita
from different organizations okay
revolutionary organizations and
students organizations like the
directorial revolutionary to the until
that you know they they had fighting
fronts okay
and then in order for fidel to control
the movement he needed to disarm
everybody else
and then he asked a beautiful question
guns for what
for what and then he demanded that
all politic all organizations that had
fought but
batista give their their guns
it seems like it was a mistake and they
all did they all do it peacefully
yes yes because fidel had
at that time a tremendous power on the
people
not because people wanted to have a
socialistic dream that he had
made them think of fidel never
spoke about socialism or
spoke good about communism he always
denied that
but he was a charismatic leader
that somehow made people think at the
end
well if you say you are communist if you
say you are socialist
put me in the list and that is the
mentality
that really made it very difficult for
us to fight in the 1960s 1961 1962 1963
fidel because still there were people
believing that he was like like a god
but that had nothing to do with whether
they wanted socialism
or not because not until 1961
fidel declared the revolution socialist
that was
the headline using the invasion of iran
where then he stopped lying in 1961 this
the 17th of april of 1961 the newspaper
cuban revolution
had a headline with six words
we will defend our democratic and
socialist revolution
until the end and he used the invasion
of iran as an excuse
to then declare socialist cuba
you mentioned that he was a you know
very charismatic and he had this
hold on the people i wonder if uh you
know or i wonder what your thoughts are
on trump
well look i am not a hypocrite
i like trump
i like the the fact that a person speaks
out
what has what he has in his mind
i credit that maybe because i knew
another leader
fidel castro who did the contrary
he lied he lied and he
lied again and he lied again until he
found the way
to say his truth
when the invasion came in and used that
as an excuse to declare the socialist
state let me clarify something about
trump okay
i am a cuban citizen still i didn't come
to this country to be an american
citizen
i came to this country to continue being
a freedom fighter
and to do that i needed to remain a
cuban
because i was committed for life if i
become an american citizen then i have
other things
no no i wanted to remind myself no
matter how good or bad i was
and i started working in in factories
in production lines in a print shop
because i love papers and printing and
propaganda
never and i had success
i made a lot of money but it never was
my intention
i didn't come here to make money didn't
come here to look for food to
buy me shoes i came here because at a
time
all the avenues in you are close to me
close
close i was emotionally destroyed after
a fall
after after an event that didn't go the
way
it should have gone and i don't see how
it would have been gone
good anyway because it was crazy what we
did
and that destroyed me and my
organization said
bonifacio i think if you want we have
the embassy for
you and you can continue working there
and that's what i did but
let me finish about trump something i
like that man i have never voted for
anybody
and i am not here to say vote for trump
in a second
whatever i don't i don't care about that
but americans have to understand that in
this country
anybody should have the right to speak
out what they think
nobody to have the right to lie okay and
not to be confronted
the media says that donald trump lies
all the time though no
what is it what is his lie i mean tell
me a couple of those
lines i don't know if he lies or not but
he's saying something openly
and you can prove he's a lie then you
know he's a liar
but but the problem is that how many
people are here
telling us lies and nobody says anything
about it
i would just say if the media
institutions are supporting
you know black lives matter the
individuals who are praising castro
and right now praising the communist
regime and
um look i i i fact check news stories
every single day
they use deceptive framing techniques
and manipulation
to present falsehoods as it were
and then when i look at the things
they've said about donald trump you know
what
he lies but he lies about really dumb
things like how many women he's been
with or like you know
how he's the best and everyone knows it
it's like really
how much money he has yeah yeah yeah but
but there's something amazing in that
even the intercept which is very
anti-trump progressive
called him simultaneously the most like
deceit decep
deceptive and honest president we've
ever had there's one very famous moment
where he's you know he's about to get on
the helicopter and they asked him what
was happening
you know with saudi arabia and stuff and
he goes oh it's fantastic we're doing
this excellent weapons deal we're gonna
make millions of dollars
and everyone and all the anti-war left
activists their jaws hit the floor like
trump just came out and said it there
was another point
where trump was trying to withdraw
troops from syria and he goes they tell
me that we can't take out our trump uh
all of our troops from syria so we're
leaving 200
you know for the oil because we're going
to protect the oil and then everyone's
just like he's just admitting
what the u.s does with their foreign
policy so
i think one of the challenges is that
there's always a risk there's a
charismatic leader who's going to come
in who's going to entrance people and
lie to them
but i have been i've been wading through
the muck in the mire for years and i can
just see
non-stop lies from the media
so it's different it's not the same you
say fidel castro was his charismatic
leader he had everybody
i mean where where was the press were
they challenging him were they were they
calling him a liar
what press he destroyed the press what
year
in uh by 1960 you could not
really you know for example i i didn't
tell you
in uh in in 1959
when the revolution took over i i began
to
think about a figure of the revolution
that was very important during the
organization of the 26th of july
movement that nobody
nobody spoke about him anymore
and and we had a radio program
where we started to talk about this uh
cuban figure
and three or four weeks after we were on
the air
fidel asked the director of the credit
station that
had given us the time to put off to put
us off the earth and that was 1960.
they had already confiscated that radio
station
they were already putting colettias
where a newspaper writes a small column
and then the government will put at the
end of that column
equality the ending phrase saying this
is a lie and then
and then immediately after that there
was no more no more dead
cuba doesn't know castro's cuba didn't
know right after he took over what was
freedom of the press
all media was controlled and it's
controlled by the government there is no
opinion nothing else
no you cannot create even good or bad
public opinion
the government is the one that creates
the opinion they want
what are we seeing now with uh joe biden
the bond administration
that they are going to that they are
currently flagging
misinformation for facebook that they
they they are
are pushing a list of the greatest
misinformation
individuals on the internet that they're
working with the dnc the democrats and
phone carriers to to censor private text
messages
so when i see a bombastic man of donald
trump
but one who mostly just insulted the
press
compared to what the current
administration is doing in in actually
trying to circumvent the constitution to
take away the rights of people to shut
down their free speech
and their allies very much progressive
leftists
in big tech it sounds like we're we're
heading towards a similar direction to
what happened in in
cuba that's why a lot more people need
to look at
you know cuba is only 90 miles away from
from our shores
and it's the perfect blueprint of what
happens when you put in place
a communist dictatorship or communism
and socialism
everything's ruined everything's falling
apart nothing has moved on that island
since 1959 that's why
people drive around in all these old
cars that they literally have to just
keep
uh inventing things to keep the cars
running you know buildings are falling
apart um
i believe it was last year there were
three little girls playing in in
uh in the street they they were killed
just from falling rubble
of a building you know everybody's
houses are falling apart but
they're building hotels for the tourists
to come and stay at which cuban citizens
are not allowed to use
i was going to say the the the the
progressives in this country say that's
the fault of the us and their embargo
no but they're building hotels in my
opinion whether you whether the embargo
stays or is lifted
the cuban people are going to be in the
same spot because for the regime it's
all about control they control
everything that comes in they control
everything that goes out
uh as it is right with the scraps that
they have they can barely afford those
scraps
uh the the average cuban makes about 20
30
u.s dollars a month and they're paid
they're not even paid in dollars they're
paid in pesos in cuban pesos but
at the stores where you go and you want
to buy something you have to buy it in
dollars
wow so how does that make sense at all
you know and it's
man it's just everything's like upside
down there's broken yes completely
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you